hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the amnesia
custom story poisonous ok this is
another very highly rated one I'm trying
to only stick if I'm gonna keep doing
amnesia Let's Plays I want to try to
keep the quality high so I'm very picky
about the ones I play so this one
there's by reindeer productions get
ready turn off the lights put on your
headphones put on your hoodie I don't
have a hoodie nope
I remember if you get stuck read notes
diaries and mementos are you all set
then press Start ah a logo interesting
and it'll present a very very nice touch
I love it
Oh fly by the village is situated far
from civilization in the Eastern Europe
it is a common here say among the locals
that something mysterious is going on
the mountains in the last 20 years many
people have been camping there but not
all of them have returned some of the
locals say it is human-like beasts
others says is wild bloodthirsty animals
the mountain hold behold a beautiful
landscape with astonishing waterfalls
and a rare wilderness therefore many
adventures do not care about the hearsay
even though they have been warned
oh I wanted to read more me and my
fiance Rachel are on the hiking trip in
the mountains so far it's been an
amazing journey
I like the production quality in this in
this custom story I like it actual
unique pictures for loading screens hi
mister grunt what are you doing is that
is that his girlfriend is that his
girlfriend yeah I mean come on man you
could do better than that
I mean no she's gorgeous but come on
headshot I just had a crazy dream Rachel
Rachel where are you Rachel
all right that's not too impressive but
I'll make up for it with my own added
voiceovers Rachel is not here but where
could she be
I'm worried that I need to find her all
right off we go
we've lost our girly girl look at Lori's
view it's phenomenal maybe you should
have been sleeping in there ten you know
with your girlfriend maybe
that might have been good without their
help
what I have nothing probably for the
best
all right let's go
ah that's nice nice waterfall nice toxic
sewage barrels I don't like water but
how old Strom threw it over a little bit
yep
he's a radioactive hunks of sewage bands
this doesn't look very helpful healthful
for the water in the nature dear bye I
hope that nobody drinks from this yeah
you just grew a third arm from swimming
through it but that's okay so long as
you didn't drink it it's like that pool
and Futurama down in the sewers going so
nice to be able to sprint is that a now
oh you're a leaf you're a very
suspicious looking leaf sorry to say is
that way let me go this way hello okay
let me go the other way first because
that looks like the way I'm supposed to
go I like to explore every nook and
cranny what dumb Oh
warning I've tried to run but the wound
is wide open and the pain is killing me
I'm taking the easy way out whoever
reads this don't go to the castle go to
the castle what's the easy way you
chopped your limbs off and jumped your
head off how is that easy
that's actually a very badass way to
kill yourself so kudos to you if that's
easy and something killed that guy I
would not want to meet the thing that
killed that guy cuz that guy was a
badass ah very nice ah this castle
looking place well I think I'll go in it
Oh was I supposed to go in through the
front door haha oops whoopsie Daisy
Bobby sorry bout that Oh No okay that's
not even oh okay I was not supposed to
go through the front door
can I jump off let's try yep damn it why
do I always do that [ __ ] you kid into
that house they probably were like no
one's gonna die this early okay alright
thank you for bonding me right here
you don't put a ledge and not expect
people to jump out of it at first I got
to go over here cuz it looks like
there's something never seen that tree
before oh no wait that's a clever use
that's a vine it's one of the vines and
they just put leaves on it nice nicely
done I always like to see people getting
creative with whatever they have what a
strange Rock hello Juliet my dear sorry
about the [ __ ] throw please Juliet let
down your hair
then alright no okay sorry anything
under the stairs
have I thoroughly wasted enough time
possibly a graphical bug I see it oh
yeah
alright I've [ __ ] around for quite
enough time to go into this castle
oh so Gary reg oh sorry I mean rare
though rare no sorry no if that's the
guy
God playing this Rachel who's in there
the door's locked
but there must be another way into the
castle maybe around the other side that
I went
the female voice actors very very nice
all right what about over here
oh wow hello there I could have gone up
this way the first time actually I don't
know if it wouldn't let me
oh right BAM head put that branch right
out of the way yeah yeah it didn't hurt
like lacerated my femoral artery didn't
hurt even a little bit I don't know what
to expect from this elderly castle but I
need a rescue Rachel totally ignoring
the warning from that guy cause if it
was me and my girlfriend was in the
castle I would be all chivalrous and
gallant and go into a monster infested
castle to save her and then I would
punch every monster in the face stick my
fingers up their nose and shove them
down a well then I'd call their moms a
[ __ ] can't move
oh hi hey baby
bye-bye Hey Oh you won't even let me go
out this time no all right so what do we
got here
I need something to lit up dark places
with
what's in here I'm still hesitant
hesitant of of closets at the moment
because of what doomed to $2.99
who's the maker of the things in the
night sorry ah this looks a Brit and it
comes with no oil that's right zero oil
oh man I love having no oil can I have
any less oil we took it all the way
enough of that
that's just silliness hello there was a
monster in here lots of notes someone
locked the door on the second floor but
there has to be a way to open it because
rachel is in there I like the level
design a lot of work has been put into
it and then like when they take care in
their level I mean the outside of the
castle woman exactly ornate but
I'm sitting here alone writing it's not
often I get the chance to be alone in
here but lately Benjamin hasn't paid so
much attention to his beloved
collectibles his old armors are getting
dusty is that Rachel is that someone
else I think it's someone else oh I see
yeah I should be on the lookout I'm too
busy smell ah what up what what really
holy crap
Wow hahaha that's the Stefano's - ooh
man
they super-sized him he's been eating
his vitamins all right oh there's
another one
all right interesting but I don't see
anything else here ah oh wait no need
this block brick in inert pieces of
crystal okay I mean the orb from amnesia
ah I like it lots of just little nuances
secret secret ah
but maybe it's nothing
I'm also astonished by finding new
secret paths around this house even
though I've lived here for so long hmm
very interesting you think that he might
be a monster grieving murderer
now of course hello Alexander it's good
to see you yeah I can't believe it took
me so long I've been playing amnesia for
a while now and I didn't realize that
the only reason this painting changes is
because your sanity goes long I did not
know that for the longest time I thought
I just randomly happened like just a
scare yeah buddy the way I guess I was
wrong
okay this looks like enough of it oh
really really you're gonna have a
painting on the wall that can be removed
in nothing behind it
oh that doesn't look good
how suspicious this blood is doing
something outside of a human body huh
the fringe as you can see I'm writing
this with my own blood if you are
reading this you may be in the same
situation as me or even worse if you
haven't met them Jett if you haven't met
them yet
oh I'm sorry there's a Swedish guy if
you haven't met them yet I tried to
describe one of them to you imagine a
human figure if it's what it were Dawn's
visible on different hand map for big
the human body birds could fit inside of
it I've hanging from the eye orbits and
worst of all it's mine so evil that
every living creatures that exist should
die if it the other monster of course
haha
it took me totally by surprise I'd close
my eyes and look down after reading that
note and then I look up and all I see is
grunt
oh man that was cool though I liked the
introduction to a monster I mean
obviously if you play that nation you
know what the monster is book that's
still cool ah oil oh I don't know if in
jump like that okay alright okay anyway
moving on
alright I really like this this custom
story so far it's off to a very good
start very nice building atmosphere nice
level nice level design and all that you
know just it has its [ __ ] together
it's like my basic requirements for an
amnesia got some story well hi hi what
uh who da la da there's nothing in here
I don't think so some behind there nope
are nothing in there maybe a hidey hole
another momento the door and the first
floor seems to be leading off to the
rest of the castle I need to open it
good call Brougham I'm actually all out
of time yeah just nothing much has
happened besides that one moment but I
like the look of this so far I think
there's gonna be a fun one so thank you
all so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next part but I